it's a distinct pleasure for me to
introduce our final speaker amid all the
luminaries that we've had throughout
this entire symposium to have someone
who's going to bridge now to the
translation Rob Califf
vice chancellor of clinical research at
Duke professor of medicine and director
of the Duke translational medicine
Institute's is I believe a most fitting
person to end this in this symposium
cardiology over the last 25 years has
undergone I think arguably the most
remarkable change of any of the areas of
Medicine interventions in prevention
diagnosis treatment have resulted in a
vastly different epidemiology of the
disease than we saw 25 years ago even
within the last decade we've seen
reductions in hospitalization rates for
my Carl infarction of 20 to 30 percent
we're seeing reductions in heart failure
hospitalizations of similar magnitude
mortality rates after keep my Carl
infarction type treatment has been
transformed and when we look decade to
decade we're seeing similar 20%
reductions in mortality compared to a
decade or more ago I think there's no
area of medicine where we've made as
much tangible change in patients lives
as a result of a combined work of basic
scientists and translational scientists
and making sure that the adoption at the
bedside by the clinicians have been
appropriate and effective no one has
been more in the middle of this
revolution than Rob Califf
Rob is a visionary who has not only
demonstrated excellence in academics but
has shown himself to be a builder by
building founding the Duke Clinical
Research Institute the world's largest
academic research organization he showed
the way in which an academic
organization to bring the values
inherent in the Academy to a place where
they were working at the interface with
business with the public with
policymakers and government and with
academics in order to deliver good
science that could guide policy we're
all better for the existence of the Duke
Clinical Research Institute and the
example it served to many other
institutions around the country and
around the world about how we should all
be working together for the betterment
of them the knowledge that can be
applied and translated appropriately for
the patients I think the general idea in
that you all know the new Clinical
Research Institute is not just focused
on cardiovascular but it focuses across
all of medicine but this paradigm the
notion of working together bringing
together various interests for the
common good is one that we should all
endorse and seek to emulate and rob was
really a pioneer at that his academic
credentials are unquestioned more than a
thousand articles one of the most cited
individuals in medicine you can see the
bio but I just want to leave you again
it wasn't about the papers only it was
producing the science advancing the
knowledge in singing full translation
for the benefit of patients and there
are many people in the country who
haven't experienced events or who have
who are alive today because of that
effective advancement of science not
just translation of what was in the lab
but actually the translation into the
clinical clinically meaningful
information that clinicians could adapt
and use so it's a great pleasure
we welcome my friend rob calif in - i'm
glad to have you as the final speaker
thanks
that's very great it's a little
overwhelming to be in this distinguished
crowd in this great place what I'm glad
to be here and hopefully give you some
different things to think about than
what you've been talking about so far
maybe a sort of simpler view of the
world but hopefully to stimulate your
thinking about how we can go beyond the
laboratories into actually improving
health as a goal first just a few
thoughts about translations yet since
this has become a buzzword I get asked
several times a day what the heck is
translation and I come to believe it's
actually a mindset and it was
fascinating for me today to listen to
Bob Lefkowitz who I remember 30 years
ago they used to tell me if you're
actually working in human beings you're
not really a scientist and we shouldn't
Sully ourselves with all these companies
he's now started several himself quite
successfully and I think it's on the way
to a whole new generation of
therapeutics that will help a lot of
people in a way that I could never even
dream of so this mindset I think should
be something that we take very seriously
also in a setting where particularly for
the clinical minded people those who are
actually sending patients in our clinics
we're increasingly being pressured to
get through the day seeing more people
at a faster clip and being told that the
mark of a good clinician as someone who
can adhere to guidelines and meet the
metrics that the health system has well
that leaves little room to be creative
about what we're doing and somehow we
need to then have these two mindsets
that are balanced one I think of is the
static mode which we actually have to be
very good at heads down do a good job
meet the standards that are in your
institution and then the translational
mode which I really interpret is
constantly considering how you can
contribute to improving the system that
you're in this might be in a laboratory
or it might be in a public health clinic
or anywhere in between
first we'll talk about in a neighborhood
now just a little bit of chiding since
it's in the afternoon and why
between you and a beautiful day and
you're probably tired and a little bit
sleepy what I also hear and in fact at
the Society for clinical and
translational science it's the last two
days I must have heard a dozen time from
prominent people when asked why is it
that we have such terrible health in the
United States what is the National
Institutes of Health doing about it what
I heard over and over was that's not our
fault we just do science
that's culture and society that's not
our phone so here we are in this
prestigious place we've been the envy of
biomedical science around the world yet
were middle of the road in health
outcomes and falling like a stone
compared to other societies we've got
the most expensive high-tech medical
care not much of it right around this
building there are health outcomes of
mediocre and the worst outcomes are
often the closer you get to these
massive institutions like Yale and do
and we're a nation of entrepreneurs in
general biomedical industry is
increasingly offshoring as a way of
doing business and Peter Kim told me
today he's not so worried about that I'm
actually not worried either because we
have a medical school in Singapore and
it's a great recipient net of American
offshoring Richard stack one of my
colleagues growing up has just founded
five new device companies all five or
venture capital founded on one condition
that they not be headquartered in the
United States that's the only condition
he had to meet beyond the idea of the
companies and so we spent a lot of time
with a community and of course all this
work none of this work is my own work
it's all done in a community thinking
about translation as a way of life about
bridging this gap between science and
outcome so that we don't become a
country that might invent drugs that are
efficiently used by other countries to
outdistance us in terms of their health
and productivity and status in the world
and in addition to thinking about
translation in these metrics that you're
all familiar with now probably going
from t1 as you go from bench to bedside
all the way
to t4 from practice to tree benefit we
also now have a chance I think to bridge
this great divide that's occurred on
this campus in other places between
schools of Public Health and schools of
Medicine between personal care that
individuals get and population care that
societies get that's the last part I'm
going to talk about at the end to show
you what we're trying to do I don't know
if it'll work but I'm pretty confident
that it's at least a segue into what we
need to do as a country to have an
American way of improving public health
so we now have these parallel systems
than in the past or essentially divided
because medical schools were all about
Flexner and biology and individual
health care and public health schools
were all about the reaction to that
which was policies and public health
clinics and periodic assessment of the
population well now thanks to the
changes in informatics and IT we can do
both at the same time with exactly the
same information and we're trying to
create a model of that so here's some of
the trends that I see in the field that
I'm trying to work in first and I think
for most it's a dominance of
communication and management of
information like every other field I'll
say more a little more about that in a
minute
second is globalization which is real
everyday the third is that there is
increasing pressure being felt at the
NIH to demonstrate that there is a
relationship between the investment and
biomedical science and the health of
Americans the next is in permanent
devices 5-10 years ago we were
approached by a lot of companies and we
were not you know in the leading tier of
institutions maybe the second tier in
terms of our laboratories HIV was
certainly one place where we had great
strengths so the people will come to us
and say we don't have enough targets and
molecules can you can we get some of
your basic science lately we've been
approached by a lot of people saying we
got away too many targets and molecules
who can't figure out what to do with all
these things and most of what we try
that doesn't seem to work for reasons we
don't understand and let's try to figure
out now how
develop products better we now have a
mandate for comparative effectiveness
healthcare reform is pressing on
accountability that is not just
discovering things of being responsible
for better outcomes and in the midst of
all this we're losing ground compared to
other countries a theme I keep coming
back to so just to put the icing on the
cake about trying to motivate you not
that I'm opposed to progress in other
areas of the world I'm spending a lot of
my time on it but particularly in the US
I think the big picture and I'll show
you some exact date on this in a second
life expectancy in functionality are
continuing to improve just recently
there was a another report from CDC that
was positive if we compare the United
States to the United States but we're
not improving as fast as other countries
in other words we're losing grams in
health status and we're much more
expensive for this inferior result but
the big change now I think is uh up
until just recently we always assumed we
could buy our way out of a problem like
this it's somehow we had enough money
that we could save the day by using all
the wealth that we have to put it to
work to rescue the situation but I think
most of us are now convinced we're no
longer in that position we're going to
have to actually use ingenuity the
old-fashioned way so the good news
mortality continues to decline on an
annual basis I always feel like I have
to show this slide so it's not totally
depressing and in fact last year like
every year since 1900 there was an
improvement in life expectancy in the
u.s. except for the 1918 influenza
pandemic and since 1950 got a lot of
this progress has been due to to
medicine not just sanitation and public
health policies but here we are compared
to other countries in the world now
still nicely between China and Cuba in
terms of our life expectancy and there's
a little debate about this because as
you as you all know the numbers are
imprecise but we're somewhere between 36
and 50th I particularly like the fact
the CIA was the organization that ranked
lowest of the rankings that you can find
in public health is 50th now if we could
debate who believes the CIA more than
other public health type agencies I
don't know but certainly not a record to
be proud of as a country and if we look
within our country we see amazing
differences in life expectancy based on
who you are and I would point out here
that the difference between men and
women is is sort of the reverse of what
you might imagine based on what you read
that is men live significantly shorter
than women but that a black male in
particular on average lives about 10
years less than a white female in this
country that is an astounding difference
and we can go to neighborhoods as I'll
show you either in New Haven or Durham
where the differences are even greater
well what about quality of care where
next-to-last in the Commonwealth
countries in terms of almost every
measure of quality of care so we can't
blame it all on culture we have problems
just in how we deliver the things that
we know are effective and if we look at
spending where the most expensive and I
think what's particularly interesting to
me is that when you write my reg life
expectancy in spending there's actually
a pretty good relationship
globally except for the United States
also of interest there was a lot of
discussion about a decade ago that we
were more expensive partly because
everything's more expensive in the US
because we're wealthier and that's a
given in international business I've
spent a little time on this over the
last five years but after adjustment for
the sort of general more expensive
factor related to the country that we
live in we're still off the scale
compared with other countries so in a
business sense we have a bad product at
a very high cost that in almost any
other business would be a really bad
deal not something that you would be
proud of but this is the thing that I
think means that we can no longer take
the position that we're going to have
sort of a rescue here by buying our way
of it you're all familiar with this
situation
and certainly haven't been in Washington
the last two days I don't see anyone
with great enthusiasm there's going to
be more investment in biomedical science
or an increase in the payment for the
delivery of healthcare maybe this will
be a good thing because it'll force us
to be more creative about what we do
with the money that we have so this is
sort of a statement to go into the part
about the way at least I'm thinking
about it and we are at our institution I
just don't accept what I heard so often
in Washington the last two days it's not
our fault because it's all social and
cultural factors beyond the reach of
scientists or universities I'd argue
there's a continuum that goes from
discovery to translation to evaluation
application in practice and community
change for which we have substantial
accountability if you go to almost any
state in the United States the wealth is
now aggregated and a few companies like
Merck and mostly though in universities
we are the wealth of most of the states
that we're in and we're the largest
employer now of most of the states that
were in Alabama that was just ravaged
15% of the employees of the state of
Alabama are employed by the State
University System of Alabama just as an
example I'm sure I New Haven there's
similar statistics that one could give
and all of this is susceptible the
scientific study and I would argue now
accelerated by a democratization of
information I'll show you more about
what I mean by that and because of our
Senden see now it's academic health
systems and not just medical centers
with an associated medical school it's
our responsibility to come up with an
American solution so now everybody else
has talked about how they got into this
I got into this because I was a young
person computers in the 1970s were sort
of a strange part of medicine and a
mentor who was interested in it who
happened to be a cardiologist so I
decided to become a coronary care unit
director and these were the sort of
statistics that we were looking at as
Harlan
the time a heart attack was treated with
two to three weeks of bed rest
we gave lasix we gave morphine we had a
few other things that we could do
nitrates but we didn't really know what
caused heart attacks and the mortality
rates were astoundingly high with these
large numbers one of the interesting
things to me is with all this discussion
about biomarkers one of the most
important biomarkers in the history of
medicine is the electrocardiogram and I
was there on the day when we were
developing the first unstable angina
guidelines for Jeanne brown wall and we
looked at all the data on unstable
angina and there were no trials greater
than 650 patients we could not say
anything useful about the treatment of
unstable angina
as we were talking about it we said you
know the problem is people come in
they're having chest pain they're sick
we measure some enzymes we do an
electrocardiogram we put them to bed and
then we wait for all the enzymes to come
back and then we declare whether they
had a heart attack or unstable angina
but by then the highest rate of
mortality has already occurred it's too
late what if we just took that first
electrocardiogram the aside as a
biomarker we weren't actually using the
term biomarker back then and we divided
the population into two groups would
that change things and I would argue
that simple classification using a very
simple biomarker led to a huge sea
change in the way we thought about the
disease and a way to identify people at
the time when the treatment would be
most effective now it wasn't just out
obviously it was the invention of new
therapies it made such a big difference
the unraveling of the issues around
cholesterol that you heard about that we
really wouldn't talk about earlier today
but also the cardiac devices the
percutaneous devices to open coronary
arteries made a huge difference the
result of all that was a dramatic
reduction in mortality and I'll show you
a little more about it but even way back
then it just seems so obvious that there
was a very rational way to go
about this you had all this discovery
science as I've discussed with
colleagues most of it doesn't work when
you put it in human beings and we've
heard you know the struggles of our most
brilliant people I'm sorry I missed
yesterday but today it was so so obvious
how much work has to go into getting one
effective therapy because no matter how
good it looks in the laboratory the vast
majority of things are just not going to
work in the human condition but if we do
the right clinical trials and we do them
well with adequate sample sizes and as I
say I've now escalated up until about
six months ago I said we need to log
orders more human participants in
clinical research I now think it's three
log orders because we are going to have
factorial combinations than almost every
disease Merck didn't just get one
protease inhibitor most companies are
developing four or five drugs for
hepatitis C at the same time and I would
argue given the combined toxicities or
combined benefits there is no way to
figure this out
other than measuring the risks and
benefits and populations but if we do
that and we do on Harlan has been so
helpful and as a national and world
leader in doing measuring what we do in
clinical practice we can see major
changes and outcomes in these diseases
so I always go back to this original
effort in acute coronary syndromes the
ST elevation myocardial infarction the
unstable angina non-st elevation we took
Richard Peto and Rory Collins advice
when they said you need sample sizes of
greater than 20,000 for most of what you
do we randomized hundreds of thousands
of people we found effective treatments
we got hospitals to measure whether they
were giving the effective treatments
very simple things that can be done in
clinical practice amazingly in the
United States when we started this in
1992
I'm sorry 2002 at that time if you
rolled into a hospital in the United
States I think including Durham and New
Haven the odds that you would get
aspirin and a beta blocker within 24
hours were less than 70 percent facade
we used to exemplify this was
paris's and to mcdonalds where with less
than high school graduates they measure
whether you get napkin and ketchup in
the bag more than ninety nine point two
percent of the time and if you don't
succeed in doing that you get sent to
mcdonald's university for retraining so
with the help of Harlan and many others
we put together a national registry
interesting initially funded by industry
and then adopted by CMS and many other
national organizations and showed
tremendous improvement such that now the
rates of use of effective treatments are
so high it's almost not worth measuring
it anymore in this condition and we also
demonstrated that sure enough if you get
people the treatments that have been
proven to be effective and here I don't
be improving on biomarkers I mean proven
in terms of true human outcomes how long
you live how well you live and you apply
those treatments in an effective way you
see a proportional reduction in risk of
being dead just as you would expect and
this is not just a slide for Yale this
is part of my standard talk about this
Harlan published I think the seminal
article that wrapped up what happened
during this revolution in clinical care
with a dramatic reduction in risk of
being dead for anyone in North America
he makes it to the hospital alive with a
myocardial infarction so the question I
keep asking is we could do this in one
condition why is it that we're so
pathetic in almost every other condition
now many people would think that we had
this problem look but as I'll show you
we certainly do not have it like and
there's much work to be done to fix the
system so not to quote someone from a
different institution too much but our
sort of theme about this has been that
what we've heard about today for the
most part has been absolutely critical
obviously I mean no one argues with it
but we can't forget the next part of it
if we don't apply what we know
particularly in human health this is
really a tragedy now this is the man who
influenced me Eugene's dad so I'm going
to quickly go through some ideas now
that he taught me
in the 1960s and 1970s and it was
essentially the concept that the human
brain is not configured to remember what
happens in clinical care seems kind of
obvious now in the sixties and seventies
that's not what we were taught but I
would argue if you go to the average
medical school and you look at the
apprenticeships that our medical
students are going through they're still
taught a lot of this sort of nonsense
about clinical acumen which can readily
be demonstrated not to be true but I got
a little enamored of this and my first
article was in the Western Journal of
Medicine 1981 I predicted that within
five years we'd all be using computers
in every patient we saw to make a
prediction about what would happen so
that the patient the doctor together
could make a rational decision about the
best treatment I was off by about three
decades but I think we're beginning to
get there and what's allowing it is
what's shown here and I think the
pressure to really transform it's going
to occur not so much from inside of
medicine but from consumerism and this
rapid amazing availability of
information which is everywhere this is
not a fake photograph and I can assure
you haven't been in Washington the last
two days on average cellphones work
better in rural India than they do in
our nation's capitol and if you think
about the computing power that's now the
average cell phone in rural India and
what was on your desktop 10 years ago
it's really quite an astounding
difference so a piece of information a
piece of knowledge that's gained
anywhere in the world right now is
immediately available to almost everyone
this is obviously bringing down
governments in parts of the world now we
may be the last bastion where possession
of the information is 95% of the game
here's some stats I've been working on
with Google 83% of adult consumers look
for health information online is the
third most frequent activity after email
and searching I won't say what people
are searching on but you can imagine
it's not pretty but look at doctors 81%
of doctors use search engines to find
medical and
Meishan and 71% star patient research
when they're in a clinic with a straight
Google search this is global this is not
just in the United States the average
dog spends less than three minutes for
search and only ninety percent only go
to the third hierarchical item that's
listed what this is telling you is that
right now doctors have access to
information which is no better than what
the average person in rural India can
pick up on a cell phone and you might
ask what we're doing to sort of be
prepared to make to take advantage of
this and then you have this with regard
to decision making from one of my
actually Eugene stats unbell who's now
at Vanderbilt if you look at cognitive
capacity and what you need to integrate
to make a decision it is simply not
possible even when I heard Charles
Sawyer's talk about today once you get
beyond about the third order of
integration of information maybe if you
get paid a lot of money as an oncologist
to spend an hour with each patient you
can do it but for most of us with most
diseases there's just no way there's no
way a doctor can remember it until we
get decision support that really works
we're in trouble
so as we begin to map what it's going to
take to go from all the state which is
ubiquitous to information to knowledge
and then maybe eventually to wisdom this
is really I think a key part of the next
bit of work that we need to do and it's
every bit as complicated I would argue
as much of the other science that you've
been hearing about today so now then the
next thing is what the question is as
Google thought five years ago those of
us in academic medicine or we the nodes
of progress or we the boulders in the
way of progress and one could argue
either way what can't be argued now
though in our article in Lancet we tried
to articulate this is that we're getting
into a situation where we're beginning
to own not only American tertiary care
medicine but because of the massive
consolidation of health systems mostly
around academic
medical centers now we are becoming
fully integrated purveyors of healthcare
to the populations in the areas that we
in have it and so as we looked at this
we said we've got to reconfigure
ourselves it's okay to have departments
we still need them like they've been
before but we've gotta have our cross
Fanning Institute's that deal with its
translation from all this tremendous
knowledge that's coming out of these
laboratories and buildings out into
beginning to understand how they might
be applied in clinical care but then
eventually how do you actually change
the health of the populations that we're
serving integrating all this knowledge
and I won't dwell on the details of the
Institute's but the effort is underway
now to have a matrix throughout the
institution in which there's a balance
of power in terms of how things get done
across the spectrum so I'm just going to
go through three or four examples that
have had a big impact on me I'm not sure
what they all mean one of the tough
questions that I'm sure that Peter asks
every day is how do you if you have a
success was it just Locker can you
repeat it because most of what we do
fails and so when we found of success
I'm not sure whether there's a
generalizable lesson to whether we were
just lucky so one thing that really
affected me greatly in terms of thinking
about how University should work is what
happened with hepatitis C and literally
the story here was that we had a fellow
named John McCutcheon who was a purebred
clinical trial esteem clinician he did a
study where the pharmaceutical firm
looking at two types of interferon the
study was a complete bust there was no
difference it was a nice New England
Journal paper but he had the database
because we when we did clinical trials
we have the database and he had the
blood samples and he was at a meeting
one day in our translational medicine
Institute and a guy named David
Goldstein was there who had just bought
up a large armamentarium for genetics
and they started talking in boasting who
was an
illogical geneticist by training said
you know I've heard about this
interferon I hear there's a big racial
difference in terms of response and I'll
bet there's something genetic thing and
John said well that's kind of
interesting because I just we just
finished this trial we got these blood
samples let's see what we can make of it
you know they went looked and sure
enough there was a single area that
seemed to account for a huge amount in
the variation in the response interferon
purely because they met and we're
talking at a meeting they had never
worked together before within
approximately six months to nine months
of their first meeting they completed
the study and it turned out that this
allele explained the vast majority of
the difference in response and because
David is a genetic anthropologist I'm
gonna move on in the interest of time
here you know he showed this very nicely
by aggregating the studies around the
world that had been done with interferon
and sort of the bottom line this is
actually my favorite slide the bottom
line to me as someone who thinks about
therapeutics every day as if interferon
have been developed in Beijing where by
the way a lot of drugs are now being
developed it would have looked like an
amazing drug over an 80% complete viral
clearance rate if it were developed in
downtown Atlanta or Durham it would have
been a total failure I think with a less
than a 35% complete and viral clearance
right and so here's a case where the
right configuration of industry academia
and several forms of academia brought
together makes a big difference in terms
of a diagnostic test this test is now on
the market David and I now spend
considerable time arguing about whether
it's been pushed on the market too fast
because the truth effectiveness has not
yet been defined but it's being used
quite a bit this got us to thinking that
maybe what we need are some long-term
relationships between companies that
develop diagnostic products and
universities that are literally full of
people developing biomarkers now not
knowing
exactly how to get them developed in a
few years to now we'll be able to report
on this one but we've developed such a
relationship with with LabCorp at this
time of a downturn in NIH funding this
is very welcome funding coming from lab
core to our faculty with a board which
is haptic an half lab core well then
what about all this difficulty we're
having then developing drugs and this is
also a really favorite slide of mine
because I was part of a very lucky
experienced the shortest time on this in
on this slide from this paper which a
lot of people quoted in development from
idea to definitive clinical trials up
six of mab where Barry Kohler had the
invention we did the clinical
development in the phase three clinical
trials Barry and I've worked together a
lot since then we've had nothing that's
really succeeded since then and that was
many years ago so there was no great
insight here I think a lot of it was
luck
I think we've got to go to a system now
where in order to increase the success
rate later on that we understand the
biology much better earlier on obviously
in cancer this is happening in a very
molecular way because you have tissue
but for a lot of other diseases I think
it's going to take a reinvigoration of
the old physiology units of the old days
but now with the modern technology of
being able to look at the entire genome
gene expression proteins and metabolites
and so we've been working hard to
develop such a unit in which you would
genetically characterize the patient
populations you would move into human
testing in disease populations as
opposed to normal volunteers more as a
way of doing things and make it much
easier for our faculty to use these
really expansive technologies are sort
of prime example being what happened
with our genetic hepatitis example but I
think the place where are most places
have made the least investment where
they should make the most is in their
formatic
because in essence the technology is
moving along very fast but the ability
to integrate this information and
reliably make sense of it is something
that most institutions are lying again
and you'll hear more over the next few
months about a case in our own
institution where people moving fast
without involving the correct
informatics and mathematicians led to
some very bad science being done that
led to inappropriate clinical trials
being done so I'm certainly not standing
here to tell you we know exactly how to
do it what I do know though is that we
better invest in informatics and Holly I
think it's very highly likely this will
lead to much better ability to divide
both on target and off target effects of
drugs earlier and then our failures if
we have the right informatics will
actually be sustainable lessons as we
move on to the next thing something that
we've also been very poor in because the
information is not retained in systems
that are reliable and just an example of
how this is playing out for us now in
sort of an interesting way it was funny
this came up in a discussion earlier
about how good life used to be and it
really this must have been amazing
because allopurinol for Galan this was a
Duke study it was the one that really
got allopurinol into clinical use it was
quite a remarkable feat of very detailed
phase three clinical trials by dr.
randall's in which he treated I think 14
patients and not only did he make us do
clinical observations but in those days
there was no such thing as help us so he
identified the patient's by their
initials and ages so you'd know exactly
who they were I don't think I can get in
trouble for identifying people from a
paper that's already been published a
long time ago but look what happened
after that
in Gao and there are many diseases that
are in similar situation with extreme
tolls on human populations that just
have not been targets of drug
development but now I think things are
beginning to pick off because the
biology is becoming real and the
question is how
going to do it we just had this case in
our own institution where it was a Duke
Convention Pegler case work the inventor
Mike Hirschfeld got together with John
Sunday who had trained at the DCR I
understood drug development got him into
an orphan drug program where the FDA
actually supported the development of
the drug and it pretty rapidly I went to
approval for people with really severe
gown and I could show you a lot of data
I'm not going to do that but what's
gotten interesting now is a the main
limitation of this treatment is that it
is a biologic and there's an antigenic
there's a response to the drug which in
a fair number of people can be quite
severe and it needs to be overcome and
the question is you know sort of who's
geared up around the country at academic
centers to help us deal with this and
the answer is there a lot of places that
could do it but I can't really find any
places that are really geared up to
efficiently look at human systems
biology and the way we need to do it
right now it's within our capability of
doing it we just have not put it
together yet part of what we're also
doing is to go global with this as many
of you know we have a medical school in
Singapore and working now with folks in
Delhi
concept we've had is that we're going to
study human systems biology intensively
probably the best way to do it is to
have multiple places enrolling at the
same time the technology spanning these
continents is really not an issue
anymore it's really more of a matter of
having common systems and a common way
of thinking about how we do it as I've
shown you and I believe this to be true
genetically I think there will be
differences in responses to many drugs
and I think the Chinese have been right
when they said you've been developing
these drugs for decades testing them in
Caucasians and then pronouncing to us
what the does is ought to be we think
you're not correct about that and I
think there would be a really
interesting story to be told as we
figure out much more about personalized
dosing of drugs now just a couple more
things as we wrap up here
so whatever happened it is why is it
that most diseases are still treated in
no fashion way by word of mouth
inadequate studies clinical practice
guidelines based on little really solid
definitive data the poster child for
this in my view now is high-dose
erythropoietin and there you had the
worst of all worlds you had a situation
where clinical trials were never done
poorly done observational studies were
used you had a single-payer the industry
that was selling erythropoietin funded
the clinical practice guidelines guess
what the guidelines said get more
erythropoietin people follow the
guidelines because they got paid more
everybody made money the doctors made
money the health systems made money the
drug companies made money the only
problem was when the clinical trials
were done we were killing people at
higher dose of our opponent and this
happened on a very large scale so the
message here is we better wake up and
not believe that just using biomarkers
is going to necessarily give us the
answer well you might think I'm a
cardiologist just preaching because
Cardiology is so good and we had an
unfortunate fellow who I'm sure you
survived and done well Pierluigi is now
in our faculty but he came over from
Italy and we said we got a great project
for you we're really smart in cardiology
we have great data on everything that we
do and let's document that by going to
the American College guidelines and the
American Heart Association guidelines
and let's tell the world that we have
great evidence underlying our decisions
so he did the study and what he you know
a pretty simple study looked at all the
recommendations and our guidelines it
just asks a question how often is it a
level of evidence a meaning that we have
adequate randomized clinical trial data
underpinning the recommendation that
we're making we're level C means we have
no idea but we have some experts who
think they know and love will be is
something in between and the answer was
the best we had in cardiology was heart
failure with 26.4% of recommendations
based on level of evidence saying now
I've given this talk several hundred
times now this these particular slides
for a reason I want somebody to show me
another field that has more evidence per
decision and so far no one has claimed
they have more evidence per decision and
in fact the empirical evidence is coming
out now looks even worse for almost
every field I think I think the
anchoring the worst is my little
brother's field of orthopedic surgery
where I think it's something like less
than 1% have randomised trials at all if
you say how often is it just some old
guys are usually sitting in a room with
their opinions it's about half the time
in cardiology they were giving people
major recommendations about a
life-threatening disease based mostly on
opinion and inadequate studies so we
just had an experience it was
invigorating to me not because of the
answer because because sometimes you get
discouraged about America having the
willpower to actually answer questions
about medicine there's a reason that
clinical trials are moving a life in the
United States where more expensive take
twice as long and have lower quality
than other countries other than that
it's a great place to do clinical trials
on average but we had a situation and
this goes back to my origins when I
started in coronary care we essentially
had two problems we had acute ischemic
syndromes and we had acute heart failure
and about the same mortality about the
same number of people during that time
we've revolutionized acute ischemic
disease we're still giving lasix and in
fact I'm delighted to say that as of
this year we finally have the first
clinical trial of gaudiness in the
correct dose of lasix that's our major
breakthrough in acute Murphy but a drug
was developed all nasarah tide based on
elegant biology it got on the market and
and was developed and sort of a typical
non definitive way of not doing
large-scale clinical trials
and then somebody took the data that was
publicly available to put it all
together and behold it looked like there
was an increase in the risk of death and
of hurting the kidneys so it looked a
little scary the use of the drug went
down but this was so concerning that
pressure was spent on Johnson & Johnson
the pharmaceutical firm to do a clinical
trial they agreed to do it so now we
have a clinical trial of a drug that
looked very promising a lot of people
had used it meta-analysis showed an
increase in mortality and renal
dysfunction and we needed to do a
clinical trial to get the truth now you
might think this will be last thing in
the world American doctors would
participate in but they got fascinated
by this question we put together a
global steering committee had a lot of
discussion and we concluded that you
can't tell anything from small studies
and putting together multiple small
studies still doesn't allow you to
really know what the truth is and
amazingly enough in a very simple design
designed to enable the drug to be used
versus placebo in the context of
clinical practice the United States
finally actually exceeded its
anticipated enrollment in a clinical
trial and beat the rest of the world
this is just a look at what these global
trials look like Peter does a lot of
these at Merck they cost a lot of money
we did this for half of the cost that
J&J originally anticipated simply by
getting rid of all of the elements of
the trial that were not contributing
anything to getting the answer and the
conclusion was the meta-analysis was
wrong there was no increase in mortality
and there was no increase in renal
dysfunction unfortunately the other sad
news is the reason the drug was
developed in the first place to relieve
dis mia there was only a very minor
effect the point of all this is
manipulating small clinical trials get
an answer that you want may give you a
reliable answer and a few people if you
really want to know about how people
should be treated in a way that leads to
sustainable improvement of the health of
populations you'd better do adequate
clinical trials and adequate populations
and measure the true balance of risks
and benefits so now the final part what
what about what about our populations
and trying to bring all this together
so I started as I began to realize this
we got data about our own community that
the worst health in the United States on
average can be found the closer you get
to a big academic center funded by the
National Institutes of Health
I mean University of Alabama Duke
University Johns Hopkins
you know Mayo may be an exception but
that doesn't count it's not a fair
population so we started looking at
Durham County and lo and behold in
Durham County we're only better than the
rest of North Carolina in one statistic
we have twice as many doctors for a
population but if we look at our
world-famous heart center our
cardiovascular mortality is only
minimally better than the state of North
Carolina North Carolina is in the bottom
25% of the United States
I only take solace in the fact that the
Cleveland Clinic the number-one heart
center in the United States is in
Cuyahoga County Cuyahoga County has 2.5
times the cardiovascular mortality rate
as Durham County so it may be the case
that the more renowned your heart center
is the more you ought to stay away from
it if you don't want to die of heart
disease and so we set about to try to
deal with this issue stimulated by the
fact that we haven't a legal monopoly in
the county that we live in it's only two
hundred sixty thousand people but when
we took over the county measure of the
County Hospital between us and the
Public Health Department about
ninety-five percent of the health care
transactions in our County occur either
in it with a Duke provider or a public
health provider in the county it turned
out our school of environment had gotten
excited about geospatial mapping for
environmental reasons and developed
really elegant geospatially referenced
depictions of every household in Durham
County with all the publicly available
information and they initially use this
for a public health use but I think when
you when you see this at me
you can tell you what the use in any
kind of health care might be the issue
was we had a lot of pipes of lead in the
pipes you could either go to every
household in Durham County or you could
stratify the risk per household also
knowing other publicly available
information like where the babies had
been born and you could go to the
highest risk households intensively and
leave the professor's alone because it's
likely that we're going to take care of
our own pipes and that's what was done
it was highly successful but this gave
us a generalizable lesson taking this
lesson and remembering this is right
after the la crosse case which is still
not over they're still lawsuits going on
and in a county where there was both a
town-gown problem and also a major
history of racial strife related to the
part of the country we're in with Durham
County haven't been one of the major
places where civil rights were taken
very seriously in the 1960s so we
engaged in a massive effort to get the
whole population involved in this and
the premise that we had was you're gonna
be better off if we know everything
about you and you know everything about
yourself when here we're talking about
your health data we're talking about
your financial data we're talking about
your crimes we're talking about your
grocery stores your churches your
schools you name it and so we developed
a system where we've now integrated the
Ducal system data the public health data
the publicly available data about the
environment and all of the other
information that you can get into one
system and I'm just going to show you
the application that we've developed for
diabetes and obesity and and the
implementation of this is just starting
this year because it took two years of
almost pure community engagement to get
to the point where we were confident we
could go forward and by the way the
response in the neighborhoods has been
amazing
we've had really no opposition to this
and their general response has been it's
about time
that's what you knew about us very
interesting response so if we look at
diabetes in Durham County I'm sure it
all came through here on the yes there
it is on the slide this is obviously a
problem which is more in women than men
and by the way one reason for this
that's it's predominantly an
african-american problem in our County
40% of our population is
african-american a lot of the men are
dead before they have a chance to get
diabetes and that's part of the problem
that we're dealing with but it's also a
disease of people are underinsured and
undereducated if we look at the
demographics of Durham County we can
show neighborhood by neighborhood quite
a bit of variation this is no surprise
to anyone in population density in
median income and n percent African
American and we can slice and dice this
in any way that you want but it
shouldn't surprise you if you knew
exactly where a Duke University was Duke
University it's right in this area we
are surrounded by populations with lower
income and lower educational status as
many universities are and this is a look
then at each individual in Durham County
now there's a method use here to
randomly vary where these dots are so
this is actually not exactly or each
individual lives but we have permission
to use the information on where each
individual lives both for deployment of
healthcare and for research so each dot
here represents an individual person
this is a look at all the people in
Durham County to have diabetes and you
can see they're not evenly distributed
around the county and there are a number
of statistics about them that we have
both in terms of their health and in
terms of other things about them now
interesting like 24 percent of these
people have not had a hemoglobin a1c in
the Duke Health System record in the
last year now I didn't dwell on it but
on the first slide I showed you about
diving
the average number of times these people
touch the Ducal system is 13 but they're
doing a lot of different things and they
may have had a hemoglobin a1c measured
over at UNC which is only 80 miles away
but you would think that if you were
being seen 13 times in a Health System
somebody would have put the human leaven
anyone see in a place where it's
accessible in the medical record and
this is a look at the 16 percent of
people who have hemoglobin a1c is
greater than 9 or the whole spectrum but
I'm interested in a 16% and exactly
where they live and who they are now
when you begin to see this and put this
in the context of the lead poisoning
example it begins to make you think
about how stupid we are to build clinics
and tell people come to our clinics when
we actually know exactly where they live
and know that they're not coming to
clinics on their own now this is taking
a look at central Durham where of course
our focus is because that's where the
problem is you can see the density of
people here you have diabetes and and
also broken down here by
african-american status and by age
because obviously your intervention for
example in a 40 aryl african-american on
average might be quite different than a
60 year old English professor at the
University and so what we've done now is
to take this information and together
with the community ask the question how
can we best deploy our troops our health
services troops to have the biggest
impact on the outcomes in the county of
Durham and needless to say it is not by
building clinics at Duke hospital in
fact I used to go to two meetings one on
Wednesday mornings was the executive
committee of the Health System we use
data like this to decide where to put
our clinics and you can imagine where we
were putting them it's where you make
the most money and then in the afternoon
we had disparities meeting we could see
our clinic should go if you want to do
improve health which was exactly the
opposite of where they were going the
beauty of this for us is because of the
fact that
have a legal monopoly it's in our
interest to actually improve health
financially and we've done the
calculations on this so they were not
going against our financial interests as
we do this just to show you the things
that we're using in deployment this is
just a look at the social services the
clinics the churches the grocery stores
the beauty salons and the barber shops
now most specialists don't think about
barbershops and beauty salons but it
actually turns out as they've shown in
Dallas and among african-american men
the social institution where the
greatest loyalty is the barbershop on
average and so teaching barbers to take
blood pressure is a critical part of a
community strategy well we've also done
this together with the American Heart
Association is to deploy kiosks that
measure blood pressure and download the
information directly into the electronic
record in the high-risk neighborhoods
among with the professor's like me I was
actually the first participant in the
hypertension part of this because I have
hypertension I just got a blood pressure
cuff and I downloaded my information
myself over the Internet but there are
no doctors involved in this part of the
intervention except for the refractory
cases because nurse nurses and nurse
practitioners can handle their
prescriptions and then finally you might
say what about the divine and the
continuity between the divide really if
you're deploying things correctly or at
least this is our theory they said once
you have data like these you readily see
that most of the work needs to be done
in the neighborhoods where people live
but there will still be plenty of work
left over for doctors and Clinics it
will just be more of the appropriate
work that needs to be done and we've
still got a lot of work to do there and
it's a joining of these in a common
informatics system that really can make
the difference so I'm not going to
identify which one is me but if we just
look at hypertension I'm looking at
cardiology clinics you can see that even
among cardiologists we ain't to go to
control and hypertension and so it's not
just that we're out in the neighborhoods
we think we have to bring this whole
continuous spectrum from where someone
lives all the way to the clinic in the
hospital
into a common system that can be
monitored as we go through it so this is
the last slide it just sort of gives the
scheme that we're using we start with a
data architecture and interestingly in
the community of Durham after this after
six months of continuous going at it
with people in the community their
number one desire to was to have a
single electronic record that all
providers could use including social
agencies so that we wouldn't be so
confused about other treatments that
people are getting and so that we could
integrate our care and we've identified
areas that are purely clinical care in
the traditional sense in areas that are
purely the community and then what we
call a partnership zone where we work
together continuously but just like
Harlan has shown in clinics and many
people are shown in hospitals we now
think we can use a demographic unit as a
continuous quality improvement vehicle
with constant monitoring every time a
person hits any part of the health
system or the community system that
information goes into the system it's
integrated and is available to everyone
else in the system so that we can
measure the health of the community as a
continuum not as something that we ask
say every year every five years as has
been done in the past in public health
so I hope what I've given you is it's a
view for where things could go this is
based on a view that a lot of this is
going to be driven by the fact that
information is going to be so free that
even if we'd like to huddle in our
little clinics in hospitals
cloistered in our fortresses we're not
going to be able to do it because the
demand is going to be there for us to
deal with information and where people
live and give help them to get what they
need in order to live healthier lives so
thanks for your attention I hope that's
been a good way to end this symposium